you know what here's what it was man I
just was in fear I just felt inferior
growing up and I just here's what
happened man yeah I met a gay man
because we both bus tables that um could
have been Italian food honoring what
kind of food it was vague Bistro is
vague Bistro all right and it was it was
it was and uh and then what happened was
he ended up having drugs he was Italian
he look like don flamenco from Mike
Tyson's punch-out can you bring up a
pitcher Don flamenco rosin his love was
that the rose in the mouth yeah that guy
that guy oh yeah bring him up that's the
first guy right there yeah let's go with
the rosin fifth one to the right one
more that guy he looked just like him
right okay and he was homosexual and he
was a busboy as well even though he's an
adult and he got me into doing steroids
and we used to run marijuana back and
forth across the causeway bridge right
pounds of marijuana and he actually did
a bunch of pills later and died driving
to an embankment but one night I'm over
at his house I know one night I'm over
at his house Princess Diana died I knew
Princess Diana was dead really I thought
Princess Diana was like the mayor of our
town or something like I didn't really
know what was going on okay you know
yeah we're sitting over this house hi to
marijuana and he started crying and
Sampras's Diana died and he had just
made us some chicken me and him and corn
and we're sitting there to having a meal
I don't know who princes Anna was I was
high as [ __ ] and then he said he had
steroids and then next couple months we
used to go I think he loved me on it
you guys ever we never made out or
anything I was 16 he ever make like
Kevin Spacey move on you're nothing like
no see buddy hold you down deal he just
always took care of me do you think it
was that kind of like almost like he was
probably bout 30 you know a thirty year
old boy you were how old at the time
that's by 15 or 16 so he loved you he
loved me in a weird way too though yeah
but just liking it but he was also the
toughest dude in the ranch I get like
dude this but in a weird way he would
knock anybody in or out he might even
knock this girl out yeah he's tough guy
I mean he was just a tough like tough
soft your dick type but know who dude
he'll suck your dick and then knock you
the [ __ ] out did you ever see him like
[ __ ] dudes or anything
dick suck no I think he might know he
would just accuse everybody of being gay
all the time which I was doing anyway -
so yes fun yeah I was like at that age
where was like man seems dude I don't
know he live with my brother though I
said him up my brother they both need a
roommate and they were good friends he
was a good friend to him a took care of
me just he was just like a buddy like I
never had like kind of like a older
brother kind of father for this like
kind of that figure he was open about
his camera said that he died yeah he was
open about it okay and he was cool and
then he and we were both Busboys you
know he he couldn't get gainful
employment because he had um he'd been
in jail in and out of jail when felony
yeah and I couldn't get gainful
employment cuz I was 15 you know so it's
kind of like that you know we met Nobby
aerospace he has the odd couple
yeah but then we started doing drawing
testosterone and we pull over on New
Year's old doing testosterone puller on
the side of the interstate and shooter
in each other's butt cheeks damn he
never tried nothing sorry they never
even touch my butt weird or anything man
really he would inject you with the
testosterone yeah I mean I was afraid to
do it yeah once a week I don't remember
what it was you know we just did a cycle
of it or was probably he was probably
grooming you he's like soon as a kid
turns 18 oh no I think I mean I'm one
for me you know yeah you cheat if
somebody underage [ __ ] yeah I mean no
but I don't think he was trying I don't
think he was doing that I never felt
that hits the sounds trying to take care
[ __ ] of that sounded that common you
know
steroids secret yeah and he just uh yeah
he was a good dude man he was he was
probably like the first yeah he's just
like a good friend man I know it sounds
crazy like you know but I think he died
I think he dated uh you know I think I
might have he told me about dates he
went on and [ __ ] you know so I don't
think he was trying to I'm talking girls
and [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah was dating girls yeah he
would come even like he we throw clay my
brother would throw parties because both
of them were partying and stuff so they
would throw parties and I'd have big
parties over there why do you think you
have low self-esteem because like like
who feel crush a room and then I was
watching the other night laughing my ass
off and you followed me and he gets off
because I didn't really get him I was
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
yeah you did yeah that you always say
that because you
yeah I don't know I just don't feel
unless it's like I don't know it I don't
feel like sometimes you notice one feel
that great I guess it's probably the
only thing like I think like when you
don't feel that great about yourself we
were talking about this one time
recently that's kind of good for a comic
like oh yeah you should know you should
I want you to go into that doll well cuz
I figured there'd be something oh yeah I
mean I just um
you know I don't know I think growing up
I this was super him you know I just
felt you know I just didn't feel that
good you know I just didn't feel that
you know I didn't feel sure of myself I
didn't feel that good I think probably I
was young I didn't have like you know
people telling me that everything was
okay you know and if you don't have that
voice ingrained in you then you just
always kind of feel like you're on a
little bit of like a you know a teeter
totter and you just feel a bit nervous
you know stability yeah there's no
stability kind of inside me so I think
that's why I tried things like doing
steroids or you know getting in a you
know drugs and alcohol or probably even
maybe comedy you know just searching out
for something to make me feel you know
just searching out for stuff just comedy
fill that void and all or no what comedy
makes it so it made us always in control
of everything so if I'm on the stage I
have the microphone I can control
everything go so if I can control how
everything goes then I can't leave it up
to anybody else to make me feel bad you
know that's interesting it limits the
percentage chances of anybody making me
feel bad so then if I get really good at
what I'm doing and if I know everybody's
laughing then they couldn't not like me
you know like they couldn't you can't
laugh and [ __ ] hate somebody at the
same time it's hard I mean maybe that's
why I do it to have to be a wizard
really to do that I just figure that out
that's interesting so I think if I can
make people laugh then I would be like
okay I don't have to worry for a second
everybody I'm okay no everybody feels
like I'm okay when you see my back
ripple and I pull myself up like a champ
like a champ through 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a guess it's a gift
it's a gift